Another item in the sort of good thing, it
was a long weekend and lots of Americans weren't
watching the news category is that Donald
Trump tweeted out a classified image containing
sensitive military intelligence.
Trump tweeted this on Friday. It was a picture
from a classified intelligence briefing in
which he's basically taunting Iran over nuclear
technology and over a a failed rocket launch
saying quote alongside the picture, he tweeted,
the United States of America was not involved
in the catastrophic accident during final
launch preparation preparations for the Safier
SLV launch at Semnan launch site, one in Iran.
I wish Iran best wishes and good luck in determining
what happened at site one. And as you can
see, the tweet went with a picture, a satellite
image, and there's more information on the
image about what things are. It's a detailed
picture. There is a, you know, signs pointing
to a damage support vehicle, a damaged gantry
service tower and this was an image from a
classified, uh, secure, uh, intelligence briefing
that the president received. That's how those
images are labeled. This was a classified
satellite surveillance image and it was very
easily, amateurs were able to take this image
that Trump tweeted and sort of go backwards
reverse engineer that it came from a particular
American satellite USA two 24.
Now the fact that we even have this satellite
and that these are the types of images that
can produce and that it was at a particular
location at a particular point in time. That
in and of itself is already sensitive information.
One of the things that's important in the
world of classified information is that you
don't want other countries to know what technology
we do and don't have and how are we deploying
it by publishing this image, Donald Trump
is not only publishing classified contents,
right? The content of the picture itself is
from a classified briefing, but he's exposing
to China, to Russia, to whoever else the exact
capabilities of the satellite used to take
the picture and it's location. Trump is of
course taking a legalistic approach and so
are his followers saying, I, we had a photo
and I released it, said Donald Trump, which
I have the absolute right to do because that's
true.
He's the president. He can declassify anything
he wants. Anything that's classified that
the president publishes is sort of defacto
declassified and that's something that he's
allowed to do. That's not the important conversation.
In fact, that conversation is a total red
herring. The question is not, is Trump going
to go to prison for tweeting this? Even though,
by the way, people have gone to prison for
a, a distributing images that were gathered
by these exact satellites. The issue is, does
Trump understand what he's doing? Does Trump
and danger the national security of the United
States by tweeting this? Is it advantageous
to be tweeting this in any geopolitical national
security or intelligence sense? And the answer
to all of these questions is obviously no.
Iran had a failed rocket launch. There are
defenders saying a picture had already been
made public before Donald Trump tweeted this.
Donald Trump tweeted a far higher resolution
image with great detail, which exposes much
more specifically the satellites that we have
are using and their capabilities.
Trump is doing it to try to taunt Iran and
in so doing, he's proving himself to be stunningly
careless with classified information, which
is not a shock. This is actually a trend.
Remember when Donald Trump was in the oval
office, he was visited by a couple of Russians,
including a Russian aspire recruiter, a surrogate,
something I believe it was surrogate Kislyak
and Donald Trump in order to appear like the
big man. He spilled secrets to the Russian
spy recruiter that we got from our ally Israel,
and of course then Israel had to say, wait
a sec, maybe we have to be more careful in
telling the United States the information
that we have because Donald Trump thinks only
in terms of what will make them look like
a big strong boy. The big boy, the powerful
boy on the playground that everybody differs
to. It's not about what's good for us.
It's not about what's good for others. It's
not about what's good for relationships or
geopolitics or whatever else. Remember that
the right went crazy. Warning us. Hillary
can't be trusted. Hillary's emails, Hillary's
email server. She's terrible with email and
classified. This and that and the exact same
people who told us Hillary can't be trusted.
The same people who fell for that are defending
Donald Trump on this. There are people who
have gone to prison for leaking pictures from
satellites like this one. Again, this is the
USA two to four satellite. It's a k h 11 type
satellite and Donald Trump's defenders are
not only defending this, they're gleefully
defending Trump doing it. If you're a foreign
adversary, you can actually work backwards
from this image to figure out, given that
these are the capabilities of the United States
satellite, how can we organize ourselves to
hide things we are doing from satellites like
this one?
Once you understand the resolution and the
capabilities of this satellite and the way
in which it works, you can then start to work
around the capabilities of this satellite.
This is the height of some combination of,
and you tell me what proportions it's either
each of these things. This is a combination
of arrogance, ignorance, delusions of grander
narcissism, cognitive decline, complete lack
of responsibility and complete carelessness
with sensitive and classified information
and to some degree of just being a bad person
who is using all of the elements of the presidency,
not just deciding where Mike pence will stay
when he goes to Ireland so that you can make
money off of him. I'll tell you about that
later in the show. Uh, but also using the
intelligence community and using classified
information and using things like our satellites
to try to taunt other countries and appear
like the big man on campus.
Let me know what you think. Let me know your
reaction to all of this. I'm on Twitter at
d pacman. The show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show and remember that we are now streaming
live on twitch pro. On a twitch at twitch.tv/david
Pakman have remember that twitch prime subscriptions
don't renew automatically each month. Many
hundreds of you signed up for a twitch prime
subscription for free. If you have Amazon
prime last month, we're now in September.
Those have expired. Please go back to twitch.tv.
It takes 30 seconds. Subscribe to twitch.tv/david
Pakman with twitch prime. It costs you nothing
and it counts as a paid subscription for us.
It's great to be back a lot to discuss after
the long holiday weekend here in the u s so
much more
of that coming up right after the break